let's let's shift gears into another um
incomparable athlete i think that's one
way of putting it dennis rodman
dennis rodman remember that
gentleman that played for the chicago
bulls i was really lucky because i was
around dennis a lot for three straight
years when i was in chicago working for
nbc right at the time that
the whole last dance happened i was
really lucky because i worked at nbc and
i followed the bowls every single day so
i was interviewing michael jordan we did
a show with dennis rodman on sunday
nights in chicago on nbc that was pretty
epic so now
during the pandemic everybody saw the
last dance it was something that helped
get us through that that was a great
documentary on espn and netflix it was
fantastic
seeing michael in that light but one of
the biggest subplots or side stories
that came out of that was rodman in that
final season 97 to 98 when scottie
pippen was out scottie pippen missed 35
games he was injured at the beginning of
the season and he had the the contract
squabble he was unhappy so he doesn't
show up rodman was kind of holding down
the fort without pippin having to work
you know a lot harder play more minutes
deliver more and he needed a break when
scotty came back so as we all know that
typically doesn't happen in professional
sports where you ask for a vacation in
the middle of the season but dennis
robin is not typical so he asked phil
phil ran it by michael and they said hey
there's nothing we can do about it he's
going to go anyway so let's say 48 hours
two days you can go to vegas and do your
thing so robin went out there oh man and
he tore it up for 48 hours so
i'll get into more details about this
about what happened on that trip
but fast forward to 2021 and hollywood
is going to create a movie on that
incident where robin left the team and
went to las vegas for 48 hours it's
called 48 hours in vegas
i'll tell you what i'm not loving most
of what's coming out of hollywood right
now they don't make movies for people
like me i'm looking forward to this and
see what they do phil when you saw this
for the first time when you heard the
headline when you dug into a little bit
what do you think the potential that
this could be a good movie oh i'm all
for it i mean it's 20 21 we need more
massive entertainment i'm right there
with you guys i mean last dance amazing
i've watched it numerous times i mean
through and through and we always have
that
man i i would love to party with rodman
just one time like there's all my
friends are like dude like i would love
to party with that guy yeah and uh i
have a feeling i have a theory
that
you know he went out there obviously to
decompress yeah but um you know i i have
a feeling like um
maybe
you know maybe he was upset more than
what he led on as far as like you know
the responsibilities that were on his
shoulders and literally was pissed off
and uh michael was told you know to
maybe go
out there to pick him up because maybe
jordan in my opinion like he's got on
his players a lot
and i know that i just watching last
dance you know you see how hard he was
on people yeah and i wouldn't it
wouldn't surprise me
behind closed doors that jordan was an
a-hole to rodman at one point robin's
like you know what
all right fine i'm doing everything i'm
out and slams the door and goes to vegas
well i think michael is probably
thinking if i don't go out there and get
him he's not coming back right i'm the
only one he's not going to answer a
phone call or an email hey phil or hey
dennis we need you back he's not going
to do that so um you're a hollywood guy
yeah do you have confidence that whoever
is producing this movie and i think
lionsgate is distributing it do you have
confidence in faith that they can get
this story right
uh do i have confidence i don't i don't
know who made it i i looked at it it
hasn't been made yet it has been made
working on the scripture it's in
so i mean everything you know with most
films it's a lot about who's writing it
is the number one most important thing
because even like a topic like this like
i'm even trying to in my head right now
i'm trying to think okay what's the
angle what is what is dennis rodman's
actual need is it decompressed well
that's not a great story right like
that's that's that's not a movie that's
a documentary um and then the second
part is
you know
how does that actually get solved
actually knowing the storyline right so
they are gonna probably have to veer
away from some of the truths or
if there's something hidden uh that we
don't know there's got to be something
there's got to be there has to be i
don't see the movie right and for us to
believe it yeah i mean it is it's
freaking dennis robin i mean he was
dating carmen elektra yeah you know he
had all the the friends and you know sex
drugs rock and roll that's what dennis
rodman was i mean you know he was in
professional wrestling and during the
season and whatnot the stories as long
as they're authentic and we can actually
get those stories from other athletes
and celebrities
man i think we're in for it yeah good
good film and i think like you're you're
high your ceiling is going to be the
hangover right yeah this is the hangover
it has to be dude then we're all very
very happy with it that's a high ceiling
yeah you know you got to cast it right
i'll get into that in just a second
here's a quote from one of the producers
quote there's only one dennis rodman in
1998 there was nobody on earth who'd be
more fun or maybe more dangerous to
party with and yet that's not even half
of who he is the movie takes you on an
unforgettable ride with the myth the
legend and also the man that dennis is
behind everything you think you know you
think you know everything about the worm
just you wait okay that sounds good in a
press release and on a movie poster but
they've already said that they're gonna
take some liberties with facts and
reality and what really happened for
instance
robin didn't go to vegas for two days or
for 48 hours he was there for five days
he was there for 120
hours and as phil alluded to the only
reason he came back is because michael
went and got him michael flew to las
vegas and picked up dennis rodman number
two it happened in the middle of the
season when scottie pippen came back in
the movie they're gonna they're gonna
make it seem like it happened in the
playoffs so i mean we saw last dance
don't try to pull that on us okay so
then what are we supposed to believe in
the movie if you're going to take such
liberties with the timeline i mean just
say it's going to be a fictional movie
then i think they should have made this
as a documentary and tried to um just
peel back with photos with memories of
of
car or people that ran the clubs um
concierge
vip services in vegas let's hear your
stories because i don't trust robin's
memory at this point with everything
he's done over the last 20 years here's
the other thing how are you going to
cast this movie to even make it remotely
believable i mean
the only guy i could think that could
play
rodman that maybe has the pizzazz the
personality the charisma that could
maybe pull it off is kevin hart so
they'd have to give him 17 inch heels
right to pull this thing off his 5'3 how
are you going to find anyone that can
remotely
provide what rodman did as far as his
presence and just and i was around him
so much
and at a lot of night events because we
would tape our show or we would do it
live in nbc and then it would always be
go out with rodman afterwards even on
sunday night here's the funniest coming
of some of the funniest things i
remember about robin you'd know he
showed up in the studio because you
could smell benihana because he would
come from benihana come right to the
studio and his leather jacket would be
full of you know would still smell like
that because they were there for three
or four hours but you know he has a big
heart he's a great guy he was so much
fun to cover so fresh so interesting so
dynamic and that's why i think there's
no chance hollywood will get this right
because there's a chance if you follow
dennis rodman around you might get
offended by something he might say or do
yeah there's that part yeah hollywood
make movies where anybody is ever
offended
so my personal belief is they're going
to butcher this movie they're going to
screw it up they're going to tarnish
this great memory and what should have
been an unbelievable recreation of it in
a cinematic form and i have zero faith
that hollywood's gonna get this thing
right
hey thanks so much for checking out that
short clip from sports now with tom
zenner if you want to see another short
clip click right here or if you want to
see the entire episode click right here
thanks for watching everybody
[Music]